the sun has been generously giving the
earth its light for billions of years it
is capable of sustaining life but also
of destroying it
some creatures bask in the warmth of its
rays while stutters get seared away into
dust even though it is comparatively
close to our earth and even though we've
been observing it for thousands of years
every day our star remains largely
understudied it remains a silent keeper
of countless mysteries
and studying it is a difficult and
painstaking task
so how well do we actually know the star
closest to us
let's see and find out
cosmo
the first in outer space
on the 21st of november 2021
the parker solar probe was just eight
and a half million kilometers away from
the sun it was its closest approach ever
to our star
this means that it was also the first
probe that got to brush against the
sun's corona
the extremely hot outer layer of our
parent star
but why was it necessary to go through a
number of technical difficulties and
approach the sun that close
what is parker after that it had to get
that near the star to areas where
everything around turns into ash
to realize the purpose we have to see
what we already know about our system
star
to begin with
the sun is a main sequence star whose
age is approximately 4.6 billion years
it currently falls into spectral class
g2v which on balance makes it a typical
yellow dwarf
the sun's surface temperature is about
5800 kelvin
which is
5530 degrees celsius but it should be
mentioned that there are both colder and
hotter areas to be found on it
incidentally the star's inner layers and
its outer corona are scorching hot as
millions of degrees
but for all that they barely contribute
to the visible radiation
the sun's average diameter equals around
1.4 million kilometers which is 109
times that of our earth
as for the star's mass it reaches 2
times 10 to the power of 30 kilograms
or
333 000 times that of the earth and
actually accounts for 99.9 percent the
mass of the entire solar system
we're used to seeing the sun is small
but in fact it is larger and brighter
than 80 percent of all the stars in our
galaxy that we know of
hydrogen accounts for 92 percent of the
sun's overall volume in one of our
previous videos on stellar evolution we
mentioned that it is mainly this gas
that fuels thermonuclear reactions for
the overwhelming majority of stars when
its temperature reaches incredibly high
values
as they merge hydrogen nuclei release
great amounts of energy and transform
into helium which gradually accumulates
in the star's center at the moment
helium accounts for seven percent of the
sun's volume and 25 percent of its
overall mass
in addition to helium stellar mata
contains other elements as well like
carbon oxygen nitrogen and iron but
their percentage is quite negligible
the sun has an elaborate structure and
is made up of several layers which
differ in their properties
a massive core is at the center of the
star estimates show its diameter to
measure 25 percent of the sun's overall
size
the core's temperature measures as much
as 14 million kelvin while one cubic
meter of the material weighs around 150
tons
it is here the thermonuclear reactions
the source of energy for our star's
luminosity around their course
every second approximately
4.26 million tons of stellar matter is
transformed into luminosity as a result
of these processes
the core is surrounded by the so-called
radiation zone which continues to the
point of 0.7 the sun's radius the
density of matter in this area is too
great for it to get mixed up thoroughly
and thus to carry heat to the upper
layers of the star
that is why the way energy is
transferred here is this
particles of stellar plasma are
continuously absorbing photons and
radiating them again
mathematical modeling shows that the
temperature in this part of the star
dramatically changes from 7 million
kelvin in its depth to 2 million kelvin
on the outer boundary
estimates reveal that a quantum of light
produced by the core may stay in the
radiation zone from 10 000 to 170
000 years and only then to move on to
the next layer of the sun
the one lying above known as the
convection zone forms the sun's
outermost layer and is comparatively
dense
stellar matter here is more rarefied and
changeable which gives rise to enormous
vortices in the convection zone these
vortices carry hot plasma from deeper
regions of the layer to the star's
surface as it were while plasma masses
from the outermost areas slightly cooled
move down
these convection cells remain stable for
10 to 15 minutes
after which they get destroyed to give
rise to new vortices again
this continuous movement of mata creates
a magnetic field which pervades the
entire inner part of the solar system
the sun is also surrounded by an
atmosphere
it is made up of several layers of
elaborate structure
the lowest one is called photosphere
this area emits most of the star's
visible light so when watching the sun
it is actually this photosphere that we
see
as for its thickness it measures from
100 to 400 kilometers with a temperature
fluctuating between 6600 and 400 kelvin
or between 6330
and
4130 degrees celsius
higher up lies a more rarefied area
around 2 000 kilometers thick known as
the chromosphere
it can be observed from the earth at the
time of a total solar eclipse or else by
employing special equipment
this area is extremely hot with the
temperature fluctuating between 4 000
kelvin and 20 000 kelvin
interestingly its outer border is
covered with specules continuously
active jets of hot gas spurting up a
staggering five thousand to ten thousand
kilometers high
the uppermost area of the sun's
atmosphere is called the corona it
consists of giant prominences flares and
emissions that may reach 1 million
kilometers in size
the matter making of the corona is
remarkably rarefied and incredibly hot
with an average temperature 1 to 2
million kelvin and the peak at 20
million kelvin it is this area that is
occasionally crossed by the parker probe
and every time the spacecraft immerses
deeper and deeper
into the blazing abyss
calculations of the energy flow released
by the photosphere will show it to be
insufficient to heat the chromosphere
and corona to such mind-boggling
temperatures this means that there are
some physical phenomena concealed in the
sun that we have not yet discovered
which additionally heat up the upper
layers there are several scientific
hypotheses that attempt to account for
this thermal paradox according to one of
them the chromosphere and the corona
gain additional energy by dispersing
magnetic shock waves
another assumption explains it as an
effect of charged particles acceleration
in the star's exceptionally powerful
magnetic field
the parker solar probe was specially
designed in order to get to the bottom
of these phenomena and to study obscure
processes in the upper layers of the
sun's atmosphere
this probe is part of nasa's project
known as parker solar probe launched
back in 2009
nine years later on the 12th of august
2018
parker took off from the surface of our
planet on its one-way journey to the sun
to fulfill its mission
however before getting that far it had
to execute a number of maneuvers to
enter the desired orbit by using venus's
gravity parker slowly adjusted its
trajectory drawing ever so closer to the
scorching blazing ball in the center of
our system
it was ready to withstand the star's
searing heat
the probe had been designed with a heat
shield
and all the equipment had been made with
a view to extreme conditions to be faced
besides parker's calculated orbit is
supposed to line the sun's immediate
proximity for a comparatively short time
after which it pulls back and has a
chance of giving out heat to space this
alleviates effects of thermal exposure
the probe's main task is to define the
structure and dynamics of the magnetic
fields in the sun's immediate proximity
also parker is supposed to gauge the
energy flow emitted by the star to
capture particles of stellar wind and to
register wave-like processes in the
sun's corona
as a side mission the probe took photos
of venus and the comet neo-wise as it
was drifting towards our parent star to
deal with the missions successfully the
probe is equipped with a wide range of
scientific instruments like photo
cameras instruments for capturing
particles magnetometers as well as
radiation and radio wave detectors
a number of factors toward this mission
in addition to critical temperatures the
measuring instruments are exposed to an
extremely powerful flow of ionizing
radiation
the sun creates strong interference in
the microwave range around itself which
means that transmitting the data
collected by the probe to the earth is
no easy matter either
still the parker probe is carrying on
with its mission with every completed
spiral of its orbit the distance to the
star shortens
in late february 2022 it is to pass
through the sun's corona yet again
in order to collect a new portion of
data
by 2024 the distance between the probe
and the surface of our star will shrink
to become an all-time short just six and
a half million kilometers
estimates show that when the probe is in
its perihelium its solar shield may heat
up to
1370 degrees celsius which is three
times hotter than mercury's sunny side
and only slightly lower than the melting
point of iron
even now the probe is whizzing at a
speed of
163 kilometers per second in its
perihelium but it will eventually
accelerate to 200 kilometers per second
which will make it the swiftest man-made
space object made so far
the probe's life expectancy cannot be
that long
on reaching the closest possible point
to the sun parker will manage to
complete several orbits around it which
is supposed to take roughly a year
all this time it will keep losing speed
and the scientific instruments on board
will be exposed to extreme temperatures
and powerful radiation
eventually they will all be out of order
and the probe itself will descend into
the scorching depths of the sun
to be totally swallowed up by a
fathomless ocean of blazing plasma
but before it happens parker will beam
great amounts of useful data back to the
earth which will help us make yet
another step in space exploration
this is a potent proof that parker's
flight will not have been wasted
[Music]
you